would you say a big part of your job
Charlotte is pitching ideas I would say
that it's the majority of the job okay I
would say that pitching ideas you're
pitching ideas in the writer's room
you're pitching ideas when you're
pitching a TV show in a in a pitch
meeting you're pitching yourself in a
general meeting as someone that people
might want to work with um I think
learning how
to make
things I think learning how to sell
unfortunately is really what it's about
and I think learning how to sell is
really just
about Clarity and knowing your
audience I think when you're in a
writer's
room it can be kind of fastpaced and
you're trying to like get a a pitch in
but if you know your audience which is
usually your showrunner and you know
what they lean towards WS you know if
they comedy forward you know if their
relationship forward if their character
forward if their story forward if
they're like they're the kind of
showrunner that really likes a good set
piece in every scene you know so you
know your audience you know who or
you'll learn your audience as you're in
the writer's room and you'll pitch to
that so that's about knowing my audience
and that's about being clear you know
that's about um sharing my ideas in a
way that is clear that it's comedy that
it's funny like I'm this is clearly a
comedy idea this is about this is a
funny situation and we put these two
characters in it and that's what's going
to make it funny because one of them
won't stop speaking with a British
accent whatever the you know so that's
what I mean about clarity about like
just it's clearly funny it's clearly
dramatic it's clearly about character
it's clearly about relationship it's
clearly this is a setpiece pitch or
something like that um and then when
you're in a pitch
meeting that is so much about Clarity
and knowing your audience am I at a
pitch meeting at Hulu am I at a pitch
meeting at Fox um is this you know is
this particular Network um trying to do
more unscripted things are they trying
to do more features are they trying to
do animated are they trying to do drama
are they trying to do comedy like if you
go into a A&E meeting with an animated
comedy you're not you're probably not in
the right place you know so it's about
knowing your audience and that's
something that your reps are to help you
with they're going to tell you who's in
the room they're going to tell you
what's selling right now in Hollywood um
and then if you are in a general meeting
you know like if you're a writer and
they and you get scheduled to be in a
general meeting let's say you're in a
general meeting with like sha DeLand or
something you get to meet the producers
at shaa land um this meeting is really
about pitching Yourself by being
yourself it's really
about demonstrating what you're like on
a normal basis
what your ideas are like what your
background is like what your point of
view is like so that people can easily
place you in work you know it's like if
I'm at shaolan and I'm having and I'm
talking about how I was born in Haiti
and I was raised really Christian and
you know I really struggle with
self-confidence then I became a comedian
then it's like they'll probably Place me
in a comedy if they needed somebody to
write a comedy on a TV show as a staff
writer or maybe they're producing a
feature film and they need somebody do a
rewrite or something or maybe they want
something particular maybe they want a
romcom and they're like oh we can bring
in Charla because she's very grounded
she has this background maybe they
wanted to romcom about like a Haitian or
something like that which is doesn't
exist but maybe they wanted that and
then so they know that I'm Haitian they
know that I have a comedy background
they know that I like very grounded
stories like just as much as possible
telling them who I am and what I do and
how I see the world and the things that
I like to do so that they can easily
Place me so I think it's just always
about pitching is just selling and like
I think selling is about Clarity and
knowing your audience and so you talked
about you know selling yourself you know
there's I think back to the the say
anything sort of Mantra you know I don't
want to sell anything I don't want to
make anything that's sold but
essentially we all have to answer to
someone and we're selling ourselves so
how do you know what the audience is for
you yeah you know I love that question
because I think the thing that has
helped me the most in my career is
always being my own audience always
being my first audience if I don't like
it it's not going anywhere like if I
like it that means there's something to
it um if I want to see it then that
means there's something to it and so I
think it's really about respecting my
own taste and my own um the things that
I'm drawn to and being able to put
myself in the position of the audience
because at the end of the day we are the
audience it's me and you um the
algorithm is people it's people watching
it do people like this do people find
this valuable and what I like about
thinking about it that way is if we're
so busy thinking about oh what does the
market want the market is whatever the
market likes what's good the market is
the audience you know when we're talking
about the market we're talking about
people we're talking about what they
like and what people like is original
stories that have heart like if you look
at everything everywhere all at once why
is that movie is so awesome cuz it's
about a mother and a daughter who a
daughter who wants to connect with her
mom um it's it's just about us wanting
to be seen as human beings it's about
The Human Experience you know so
ultimately I think that um we are the
audience and you should just and
sometimes you know
that might not have wide appeal and
that's okay but ultimately I'm my first
audience and I am a stand in for the
audience okay so if we think how though
the audience will change their likes the
tempo when you were 24 and you gave
yourself 10 years maybe you didn't tell
anybody but I love the story did you
know what you were the audience for and
has that changed at the time you know I
did know what I was the audience for
because I didn't see myself reflected in
a lot of these shows that I was watching
like at the time I think I was watching
like girls I think on HBO I was watching
Lena Denham and I was
like you know even when I was living in
that neighborhood or hanging out in that
neighborhood you don't I don't see
myself reflected in that show in any way
um and then when a black black character
was in that show it was very much about
them being black and not just about them
being a person and how they fit into
that story um so I just felt like I just
wanted to write stories about imperfect
black girls about black girls that were
inappropriate about black girls that
were goofy that were um that were that
were a little bit promiscuous because
that was something that I never saw and
really or like promiscuous in a way that
wasn't demonized or wasn't like looked
down on um in a way that celebrated
sexuality uh because these were things
that I felt that like I really struggled
with and I wanted to see so I think that
yes my audience has changed but my
audience is also grown with me because
the things that I put out are things
that are relevant to me at at this stage
of my life and it's what whatever my
audience is watching they've grown with
me each writing job is yourself proving
yourself for the next job so it's like
you're in one job and you're kind of
almost audition for the next one because
that showrunner or someone else has a
one of the staff writers they may become
a showrunner yeah I actually think
that's one of the hardest things at
least for me uh in the writer room was
always feeling like I'm on like in every
meeting I'm on like because this is you
know someone that could potentially hire
me for the next thing and the thing is
that unfortunately it's true um
unfortunately you are kind of always
audition
but I
think the positive thing about it is
that it kind of just is a good way to
remind you that this is work because I
think that sometimes the looseness of
the industry and the fact that like even
when you're in a writer room where it
was very competitive to get in and to be
hired um it's very like relaxed it's
very relaxed or it can be uh in in a lot
of the the rooms some rooms are not that
that relaxed but I think there's like
a frequent blurring of like professional
lines like we're friends we're a family
we're you know we're just goofy writers
you know what I mean but like at the end
of the day this episode cost like
millions of dollars and you're getting
paid a lot of money to like and you're
working a lot of hours and the the
stress is there the pressure is there
from the network the studio uh you you
wanting to make the audience happy you
wanting a hit show so there's a lot
going on that puts pressure um but I
think remembering
that uh you're at work and kind of
having to be on is a little bit good
because it keeps you on your toes and it
keeps you um present and attentive and
contributing um
because the difference is that once you
get
hired you do have to prove your value
like it is a job um and it's not about
like your feelings it's not about you
know my friend didn't my showrunner was
didn't like me today it's about did you
contribute today you know were you proud
of the work that you did today at work
uh cuz you are at work and um that is
unfortunately or fortunately you know so
I think for some of us uh at least for
me as an introvert it's okay because
then I get to compartmentalize like when
I'm about to be on camera or when I'm
about to be um in a meeting in a general
meeting or in a pitch meeting or
whatever I'm at like I know I need to be
at attention I need I know I have to
have done my work at least if I want to
feel like I did a good job that's what I
have to do uh and I think that that's
okay because that is our work and that's
what we do and it is the nature of the
work that we have to show up and we have
to we have to perform um to make
ourselves proud and to contribute as
much as possible to the Productions that
we're a part of he you know it's
interesting that you said that that's
kind of reframed some things for me
because you're right being in the
entertainment industry even if it's your
on set as an extra or whatever there is
a lightness and everything's all fun and
nobody wants to be too much of a downer
but it is still work and you still have
boundaries and there's still
professional lines you don't cross and
things like that absolutely and I think
it's important to remember just because
I think it's a way for us to not
necessarily take some of the rejections
personally uh if if my idea doesn't get
into the episode if um you know if my
writing isn't particularly liked or
isn't used or is deleted and you know
the showrunner rewrites me or something
like that it's like it helps me not take
it so personally because if I'm like oh
that's my friend that's deleting my work
then it really hurts my feelings but
it's like that's my boss or that is my
coworker who is a higher level writer
that's rewriting me because they know uh
what the people that they have to answer
to are looking for or they have a
certain standard that they have to
uphold for the show or whatever it is
you know like if some if you know the
room can be very Democratic it's like if
something's funny everybody laughs if
it's not funny nobody laughs um or maybe
you know the showrunner think is really
funny and nobody else think it's funny
but that's how democracy Works in a
writer's room if the showrunner thinks
it's funny it gets in the show so I just
think that it helps
depersonalize some things that can feel
very personal because it's creative work
it's important to remember that at the
end of the day you are at work and this
is about contribution uh not about you
being validated and like praised all the
time